[Music]
the only question you need to ask
yourself while studying the third law is
what happens when two objects interact
with each other what happens when you
place an object on the table the object
exerts a force on the table and the
subject exert an upward force on the
object there are two forces that result
from this interaction a force on the
table and a force on the object the
magnitudes of the two forces are the
same but the directions are opposite
these forces are called as action and
reaction forces the force exerted by the
object on the table was an action force
and the force exerted by the table on
the object is the reaction force what we
saw here is nothing but a display of the
Newton's third law of motion every
action has an equal and opposite
reaction that's how simple the third law
is every action has an equal and
opposite reaction
it means that when two objects interact
there is a force on each object the
magnitude of force on the first object
equals the magnitude of force on the
second one and what about the direction
the direction of force on the first
object is opposite to the direction of
force on the second one let's talk about
more examples while the Frog is swimming
it pushes the water back and the water
pushes its body forward now let me ask
you a question say a bird is flying
upwards will the Newton's third law
apply here sometimes the third law is
not so obvious you'd probably say that
the bird is the only object here and
there is no second object but that's not
correct the ways of the bird push the
air downwards and the air pushes the
bird upwards action and reaction forces
make it possible for birds to fly we
take one last example to understand
something very interesting about the
third law what happens when a gun is
fired you're right it
exert the forward force on the bullet
and the bullet exerts an equal and
opposite reaction force on the gun and
this exists in recoil of the gun a
perfect example of Newton's third law
but hold on if the force exerted by the
gun on the bullet is the same as the
force exerted by the bullet on the gun
then why doesn't a gun recoil with the
same acceleration as the bullet the gun
recoils yes but it doesn't recoil at the
same acceleration at the bullet right
same magnitude of forces but different
accelerations why do you think this
happens okay
so if your concept of the second law of
motion was clear you wouldn't really be
surprised with it
the second law of motion says that the
force is the product of the object's
mass and acceleration or the
acceleration of the object is equal to
the force over its mass what does this
tell us yes if the mass is more then the
acceleration will be less in this
example the mass of the gun is much more
than that if the bullet hence the
acceleration of the rifle is lesser than
that of the bullet if you're in a boat
and step out of it onto the land there
are two forces involved you pushing the
boat behind and the boat pushing you
forward and that's why you see the boat
go behind when you go forward now let's
say a sailor jumps off a huge ship the
Sailor does apply a force on the ship
and the ship also applies a force on the
sailor but do you think the ship will
accelerate as much as the sailor
naturally and I think you know why
you
[Music]